in den fliegerhorst rom offs gegen die
österreichischen langen leben wird
kräftig investiert im oktober 2020
unterzeichnet verteidigungsministerin
klaudia tanner mit den öbb einen vertrag
über den ausbau der bahnstrecke zwischen
thun und dem fliegerhorst um die
versorgung so umweltfreundlich wie
möglich zu gewährleisten
auch ein biomassekraftwerk ist an diesem
standort bereits geplant heute eröffnet
anna mitglieder österreichs
landeshauptfrau johanna mikl leitner
einen weiteren meilenstein in der
sanierung des fliegerhorsts das
unterkunftsgebäude der für die grund-
flieger abwehr truppen schule wurde
generalsaniert
[Musik]
wie diese ausgestaltet und renovierte es
geht letztendlich umgehend menschen es
geht um die menschen die hier ihre
ausbildung erhalten und später mit
vollem einsatz auch für die sicherheit
unseres landes sorgen und für diese
einsatzbereitschaft bedankt sich auch
landeshauptfrau johanna mikl- leitner
und unterstreicht einmal mehr die
wichtigkeit eines gut ausgerüsteten
bundesheers ich denke die
verschiedensten herausforderungen an die
cyber attacken oder anfang geliehen du
es auch in der zukunft begleiten nun
fall beschäftigen
um für all diese herausforderungen noch
besser vorbereitet zu sein wird in den
fliegerhorst brunowsky weiter investiert
das sind zum einen weitere baumaßnahmen
im bereich der unterkünfte und auch beim
stabsgebäude ebenso wie bei der
fliegerischen infrastruktur hier
notwendig wird die frau landeshauptfrau
hat er schon den zukauf der ein
hubschrauber angesprochen die das auf
notwendig machen und ebenfalls eben für
die umgerüsteten blackhawks